[Musique]
pourquoi ne jamais abandonner
pourquoi ne jamais lâcher la faire
pourquoi
ben oui pourquoi
quand ça devient dur compliqué pourquoi
ne pas abandonner
quand on ne se sent pas capable de faire
quelque chose pourquoi ne pas lâcher
l'affairé reste est tout simplement dans
sa zone de confort
quand les autres les autres là vos
familles et vos proches vous dit c'est
de la folie et qui vous conseille
d'abord notre d'abandonner pardon
pourquoi ne pas les écouter
parce que lorsqu'on abandonne au début
on pense que c'est la bonne solution qui
avec sa sphère
mais quelques temps après vient tout
autre sentiment
leur gré
le regret un des pires sentiments que
l'on puisse ressentir
vous savez pourquoi on regrette quand on
abandonne
on regrette parce qu'on réalise qu'on
aurait pu faire mieux et aller plus loin
n'a pas été au bout de soi-même
on regrette parce qu'on réalise qu'on ne
sait pas s'est battu
on regrette parce qu'on sait laisser
polluer par les autres qui nous ont
convaincus qu'on n'en serait pas capable
est-ce que vous est déjà arrivé
d'abandonner
alors que celles ou ceux qui ont déjà
abandonné un projet une activité haute
lève la main allez soyez au tout ça
waouh
sincèrement n'ayez pas honte je vais me
faire une petite confidence ça m'est
arrivé à moi aussi
et ouais
alors c'était en 2005 et lors de ma
première participation à koh lanta
j'avais 21 ans là c'est pour de vrai
j'ai 21 ans
et je postulais vraiment par curiosité
pour voir si le casting n'était pas
bidon et surtout pour savoir s'il y
avait du piston ou pas je vous rassure à
aucun moment je m'étais dit que moi
combat j'allais faire koh lanta à ce
moment là faut savoir qu'au départ on
était plus de 50000 postulant que le
casting se dérouler sur quatre mois avec
quatre étapes éliminatoires chacune je
passe les étapes une à une et
franchement j'ai joué le jeu à fond
jusqu'à ce fameux coup de téléphone de
la directrice de casting qui m'annonce
que je suis sélectionné
haye n'applaudit pas j'étais plus
glauque et
n'applaudissez pas à la base moi j'ai
postulé pour park par curiosité j'ai
jamais dit que j'allais faire koh lanta
non franchement j'ai ri jaune gamme
appelée jazz qu'est ce que j'ai fait
mais je parle à koh lanta moi c'est pas
fait pour moi j'avais même pas nage
allez pas vous rendez compte de la folie
après réflexion je me suis dit pourquoi
pas mais là ma décision n'était pas
définitive visiter encore beaucoup et
puis il faut savoir qu'en face de moi
j'avais un barrage de choc mes parents
pour vous expliquer un petit peu le
concept pour une parents qui étaient
très dans les traditions les coutumes et
la religion passe à la télé c'est pas
possible surtout à koh lanta ou en en
mayenne dans toute la journée
je savais que mes parents et ma famille
n'avait jamais accepté
un mois plus tard je l'avais toujours
pas dit à mes parents et quand les
journalistes sont venus faire mon
portrait c'est à dire qu'il suivait mon
quotidien sur une journée je joue à
cache-cache pour pâques un membre de ma
famille me surprennent je précise car ça
a son importance qu on est une famille
de sept enfants
bref ils m'ont suivi au travail la salle
est parce que c'est à paris qui en a
fait une séquence parc à côté de chez
moi à nanterre la juge cho
et pour finir on a fait une séquence à
la piscine et devinez sur qui je tombe
ma petite soeur de 10 ans qui est avec
sa classe
non seulement à makram avec les caméras
mais en plus ça ma balance à mamers est
traître
en rentrer à la maison le soir ma mère
inspecteur columbo m'a posé plein de
questions et j'ai fini par lui avouer
que je participer à koh lanta
sa réaction le défunt ont fait pas ça
chez nous c'est pas fait pour les femmes
moi qui lui réplique firman mais si
maman dans les saisons précédentes il y
avait des femmes et vous savez ce qu
elle me répond
oui mais pas de femmes noires
aïe
vous savez cette parole de maman est
restée longtemps dans ma tête parce
qu'il était vrai que si je partais je
serai la première femme noire à
participer à koh lanta
un mois plus tard
j'embarque quand même pour l' aventure
malgré le refus ma famille de me
soutenir l' aventure commence bien on
nous largue en pleine mer appelle le
jour levé on doit rejoindre le rivage à
la nage aïe aïe
il y avait 400 m à nager je vous avais
dit que moi là bas j'avais pas l'âge et
je saute dans l'eau je fais quand même
100 m tellement je galérais vous savez
il ya des plongeurs pour assurer notre
sécurité au fond de l'eau on les voit
jamais ces gens là quand tu les vois ce
qu'ils aiment galère le mec il est sorti
de l'eau avec son sa combinaison son
masque il a enlevé le truc et puis ma
tracter comme une princesse jusqu'à la
plage à la classe 1 j'ai pas calculer
mon coup mais tant mieux j'étais pas
fatigué
entre nous le début d'aventuré été très
difficile pour moi parce que je me
sentais pas à ma place
je me mettait la pression et j'avais
aussi cette pression où je savais que
j'étais la première femme noire à
participer à cette aventure donc j'avais
pas le droit de me louper
d'un côté je me devais de représenter
cette communauté et d'un autre je me
disais que je leur giron de par ma
présence
plus j'avançais dans l' aventure plus ce
sentiment grandissant mois au point qu
32e jours de survie une semaine avant la
fin j'ai demandé à mes compatriotes
davanture de voter contre moi pour
sortir
oui j'ai abandonné
j'ai abandonné
et cet abandon m'a servi de leçon pour
le reste de ma vie
comme beaucoup de personnes qui
abandonnent au début je pensais que
c'était la bonne solution qui avec ça à
faire mais quelques temps après j'ai
ressenti ce fameux sentiment qu'on
appelle leur gré aïe ça m'a fait mal
ça m'a fait très très mal
parce que j'ai réalisé que j'aurais pu
faire mieux aller plus loin
j'ai regrettés parce que j'ai pris
conscience trop tard que je n'avais pas
été au bout de moi-même que je mettais
pas assez battu
j'ai regrettés parce que j réalisais que
je me suis laisser polluer par les
autres ma famille et mes proches qui
m'ont convaincu je n'en étais pas
capable et surtout que je n'avais pas ma
place dans l'aventuré
j'ai regrettés parce que je me suis
rendu compte que j'avais fait une erreur
vous savez dans la vie n'y a pas
d'erreur mais uniquement des expériences
pour nous apprendre à réaliser qui nous
sommes oui j'ai regretté d'avoir
abandonné cette aventure koh lanta mais
cet abandon m'a servi de leçon pour le
reste de ma vie ça m'a servi de leçon
parce que depuis cet abandon je me suis
dit plus jamais ça je ne veux plus
jamais ressentir ce sentiment de regret
depuis 11 ans maintenant je pratique le
triathlon et la course de demi-fond un
bon niveau et vous savez quoi je
m'entraîne entre 12 et 14 heures par
semaine pour performer quand ça devient
difficile je me dis souvent cette phrase
que je me répète plusieurs fois dans la
tête
la douleur est temporaire mais l'abandon
est définitif et ça me permet de
résister
j'aime me dépasse et j'aime me surpasser
j'aime avoir mal et performer
si je n'avais pas connu la douleur de
l'abandon je n'en serais jamais arrivé
là
alors maintenant que je vous ai expliqué
pourquoi ne pas abandonner je vais vous
donner quelques astuces sur comment ne
jamais abandonner ou plutôt comment
résister à l'abandon
premièrement lorsque vous déterminer un
objectif
demandez-vous pour qu'ils vous le faites
pour vous pour vos proches vous rendre
fiers votre entourage
sachez que plus votre objectif est
personnelle et que vous le faites pour
vous une big man et plus votre
motivation sera grande
si vous le faites pour les autres vous
aurez plus de facilité à abandonner
deuxièmement fixez vous des petits
objectifs quotidiens hebdomadaires
mensuels et annuels qui vont vous
permettre d'atteindre votre objectif
final atteindre ces petits objectifs
vous maintiendra motivé pour atteindre
votre objectif final parce qu'à chaque
fois que vous réussirez ces petits
objectifs vous serez fiers de vous et
vous aurez envie de continuer d'aller
plus loin
lors de ma deuxième troisième et
quatrième participation à koh lanta je
me suis jamais dit que l'aventuré allait
durer 40 jours vous rendez compte de la
pression pour le mental 40 jours à
crever la dalle celle où
je me projetais plutôt conseil par
conseil pour ceux qui ne savent pas un
conseil éliminatoires c'est tous les
trois jours dans koh lanta alors lorsque
je sortais de là je me disais allez
encore trois jours de plus et ainsi de
suite et j'ai atteint la finale à deux
reprises en 2010 et 2012 sans jamais
pensé une seule fois à l'abandon
troisièmement
accrochez-vous atteindre son objectif de
vie n'est jamais facile il faut que vous
en ayez conscience
au début c'est facile tout roule mais
attendez vous à des hauts et des bas à
faire des sacrifices a craqué et à
souffrir lorsque vous traverserez ces
périodes difficiles
accepter le est rentré vous dedans pour
continuer parce que si c'est dur c'est
que ça en vaut vraiment la peine
c'est vers la fin souvent que c'est plus
dur lorsqu'on approche de la ligne
d'arrivée on a envie d'abandonner parce
qu'on ait épuisé physiquement et
mentalement on est stressé en doute même
de nouveau lorsqu'on fait un marathon
par exemple les premiers kilomètres sont
faciles mais à partir du 30e kilomètre
c'est le déclin on déchante on est donne
rouge et puis on approche de la fin et
plus envie d'abandonner c'est le mur
lorsque ça vous arrivera il vous suffit
juste de regarder en arrière et tout ce
que vous avez déjà accompli à ce moment
là vous devez vous dire mais j'ai pas
fait tout ça pour abandonner là ce
serait trop long
pensez à tous les sacrifices que vous
avez fait pour en arriver là et surtout
rappelez vous pourquoi vous vous êtes
lancé dans ce projet
celle aventures de votre y
respirer
ça va aller
c'était combat pour vous apprendre à ne
pas abandonner merci
[Musique]